bonsoir bienvenue pour une nouvelle
édition de municipales 2014 sur TVfil 78
je recevrai dans un dans un instant
pardon Michel Laugier le maire de
Montigny-le-Bretonneux divers droit il
brigands nouveau mandat Alexandra
Rosetti ancienne première adjointe au
maire UMP de Voisins-le-Bretonneux
aujourd'hui dans l'opposition viendra
aussi nous expliquer pourquoi elle
entend se présenter en mars contre
Alexis bieds sous l'étiquette peut-être
de l'udéi nous évoquons une nouvelle
fois la situation à Maurepas avec l'UMP
qui vient de faire son choix entre ces
deux candidats comme le PS d'ailleurs et
puis l'actuel adjoint au sport de
Maurepas sans étiquette Michel est selon
lui aussi dans la campagne enfin côté
modem remplaçant a été trouvé à
Guyancourt aux responsable local qui a
décidé lui de se rapprocher du maire
socialiste nous ferons le point sur tous
ces dossiers au cours de cette édition
le premier invité de ce soir c'est donc
Michel legier bonsoir bienvenue sur ce
plateau mère de Montigny depuis 2004
suite à la démission de Nicolas Abou
vous avez par le passé était son
directeur de cabinet 2001 vous êtes
devenus son premier adjoint en charge de
l'action sociale vous avez été élu sur
votre nom en 2008 avec 60,80% des
suffrages exprimés sous l'étiquette de
l'UDF des c'est à dire sous l'étiquette
du Mouvement Démocrate du MoDem vous
serez candidat en 2014 sous quelle
étiquette je suis sur l'étiquette Michel
legier et soutenu par différentes
formations politiques tout simplement
aujourd'hui je ne suis membre d'aucune
formation ce qui ne m'empêche pas de
mener une liste à Montigny et de gérer
la ville comme les habitants de
souhaitent alors quels sont les
formations qui vous ont apporté leur
soutien à ce jour j'avais Montigny fait
partie des villes de plus de 30000
habitants donc à ce jour les
investitures ne seront donnés que par
Paris parce qu'il y a que Paris qui peut
des les investitures ça sera fait dans
quelques semaines alors pour l'instant
tout de même on sait que du côté de
l'UMP départemental c'est au vers votre
candidature que le choix s'est porté
même si effectivement ça doit être
tranché ensuite au niveau national
puisque c'est une commune de plus vous
l'avez précision que aujourd'hui les
fonds
politiques de droite et du centre
sont tout à fait unanimes sur mon nom
voilà simplement la officiel
interviendra que dans quelques semaines
on parle de l'UMP on parle de l'UDI
également du MoDem on est en discussion
vous êtes en discussion et où en sont
ces discussions vous attendez que ce
soit au niveau national que ce soit
tranché les décisions
se passent bien au niveau local donc
faut-il que ce soit en périnée au niveau
national une discussion porte sur quoi
justement quand on doit se mettre
d'accord sur une investiture c'est sur
une place sur la liste que vous allez
composer ensuite nombre pour le moment
la seule chose que je fais c'est que je
suis en train de rassembler très
largement autour de moi et nombreux sont
les inhibantins qui souhaitent venir
travailler à mes côtés sur la liste donc
après les formations devront faire leur
choix elle-même moi j'ai pas approuvé ce
que je peux faire ou ce que je dois
faire sur Montigny je pense que le bilan
qui est le mien est largement suffisant
mais vous nous disiez ne pas faire
partie d'un parti politique justement
vous n'êtes pas de carte que ce soit
l'UMP que ce soit au MoDem à l'uder
aujourd'hui une carte je n'ai rien
demandé je n'ai aucune carte je n'ai
rien demandé et aujourd'hui je suis
soutenu par une formation politique vous
faites ce choix pas vous engager
clairement auprès d'une formation parce
que aujourd'hui je ne retrouve pas mais
vrai valeurs dans les formations en
présence tout simplement je suis
d'accord avec certaines de leurs idées
mais je ne partage pas tout donc j'ai
pas besoin d'avoir un engagement
militant pour diriger la ville de
Montigny-le-Bretonneux comme je le
souhaite et surtout on a des équation
avec ce que souhaite les habitants je
peux vous demander également votre
regard sur la situation peut-être à
l'UMP parce que j'insiste là mais l'UMP
vous soutient Valérie Pécresse vous
soutient dans le département pour être
très clair et qui chapronent ce parti
cette formation au sein du département
puisque c'est la responsable
départementale de l'UMP qu'elle regarde
vous portez sur la situation dans ce
dans ce parti d'opposition entre ces
guerres entre Fillon Copé Sarkozy ça
vous intéresse vous êtes détaché de tout
ça non je suis pas détaché parce que je
savais quand on est engagé en politique
même sur la politique locale on est on
est très marré de tout ce qui peut se
passer ailleurs on voit aujourd'hui dans
dans l'ensemble des parties ça ne va pas
très bien dans l'ensemble des parties
après peut-être des résultats qui sont
de moins en moins surprenants par
exemple comme comme sur Brignoles donc
aujourd'hui il est temps de se ressaisir
il est temps d'avoir de véritables choix
et de véritables actions je crois que
les Français et les habitants de
Saint-Quentin de Montigny attendent
surtout de l'action et des convictions
profondes et surtout des choix bien
définis brignols partiel du Front
national face à l'UMP c'est une
situation qui vous inquiète vous y
croyez à cette poussée du Front National
au municipales en 2014 au municipal non
parce que le Front national n'est pas
capable de pouvoir mobiliser autant
c'est-à-dire monter des listes dans dans
les villes c'est plus d'investisseurs
que c'est pas d'aujourd'hui à travers la
France et on parlait éventuellement
d'une liste Front Nationale aussi sur
Montigny aujourd'hui on peut tout dire
on peut tout dire aujourd'hui on en est
aux intentions de liste voilà donc
certains ont des intentions de liste on
verra on verra début mars à la date
limite du dépôt des listes combien
auront été capable de pouvoir monter une
liste et vous avez une liste
fondationale est-ce que ça vous
inquiéterait comment vous allez
mobiliser est-ce que on parle
de maquette absolument pas puisque moi
je suis sûr de l'action que je mène sur
Montigny et je sais très bien que les
sédimentaires s'y retrouveront alors
quel bilan vous faites justement de
votre action sur ce mandat écoutez sur
ce mandala je pense que il y a pas il y
a pas dans en France une ville de 35000
habitants qui aujourd'hui peut se
Tarrier d'avoir le même mandat que ce
monde il bretonneur nous avons sorti de
très grands équipements nous allons nous
avons fait des normes travaux je ne
pourrais citer que l'arrivée du
Vélodrome qui sera inaugurée dans
quelques semaines maintenant le 30
janvier les travaux de la gare et de ses
abords ces gamètes là 24 millions
d'euros qui ont été investis pour
essayer de donner à Montigny à
Saint-Quentin une gare digne d'une
dynamisme qui est le nôtre c'est
l'arrivée aussi du FR des sciences de la
santé c'est aussi cet été l'arrivée d'un
EHPAD sur Montigny je vous rappelle
quand même qui a trois EHPAD qui ont été
créés dans le département de Yvelines
dont un surmonting Bretonneux il sera
donc un des rares un des rares dans les
dans les 10 prochaines années avoir les
gens pour les personnes âgées qui verra
le jour sur l'ancien site de la
communauté avec à côté aussi de
résidence au service puisque on fait
quelque chose de très très important
c'est aussi j'allais dire tous les
travaux que nous avons fait dans nos
équipement que ce soit dans les dans les
écoles qui ont été entièrement
rébellités comme elle est l'école marine
Noël dans les crèches c'est aussi tous
les travaux d'embellissement de la ville
de tous les espaces verts que vous
pouvez voir tous les square que nous
avons amélioré encore et que ce soit le
soir du poirier Saint-Martin qu'on a
inauguré il y a quelques jours ou tout
simplement l'année dernière le soir au
pays sur le quartier des prés donc vous
voyez bien mais Montigny continue à se
développer continue à avoir une qualité
de vie et je parle même pas en plus des
arrivées dans le monde économique
regardez l'arrivée du siège de c'est que
même monsieur monter une Bretonneux ce
sont encore des emplois qui arrivent sur
notre territoire ce sont aussi des
recettes qui arrivent aussi bien pour la
communauté d'agglo que pour la ville de
Montigny et je suis dire encore l'ESTACA
l'ESTACA dans les travaux en commençait
à voir une grande école d'ingénieurs sur
le territoire sur notre campus
universitaire une école qui était
jusqu'à présent porte son Péret sur
Levallois et qui arrive sur Montigny
c'est quand même extraordinaire de
pouvoir permettre à nos jeunes d'avoir
un parcours de la crèche jusqu'à
l'université en janvier de nous quittons
le territoire communal mais alors à vous
écouter ce sera difficile de faire mieux
pour le prochain mandat ça va être
difficile d'élaborer un programme
puisque toutes ces réalisations ont été
faites je voudrais tout de même savoir
sur la question de l'encycurité aussi
peut-être je peux vous poser cette
question étant donné que sur le centre
commercial de l'espace Saint-Quentin
régulièrement on entend revenir des
problèmes d'insécurité des commerçants
qui se plaignent des agressions aussi au
début du de cette année il y a une
policière qui avait notamment été
volonté sur ce site
la sécurité
c'est un enjeu dans toutes les villes de
France il y a pas qu'à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux sauf que déjà
monté les Bretonneux nous y travaillons
depuis très longtemps la police
municipale est déjà plus de 20 ans la
vidéo surveillance nous nous y a nous y
sommes depuis déjà plus depuis de 15 ans
et on continue toujours à développer et
les outils mettre en place aussi
j'allais dire des actions de prévention
avec nos associations et surtout un
travail de plus en plus étroit avec le
commissariat de police alors il y a
l'effet qui sont liés à l'insécurité et
après vous vous avez aussi le sentiment
d'insécurité donc c'est tout à fait
différent il y a là aussi il y a
quelques personnes sauf que il y a eu un
moment où moi je ne peux pas je ne peux
pas faire en sorte que n'importe quel
individu ne puisse pas se promener dans
les rues de Montigny sauf que là on
s'est concerné ce centre ce centre
commercial 150 ans Yvelines qui est
situé à Montigny-le-Bretonneux ce sont
des
des incidents entre des policiers il y a
bien eu un incident qui a été monté
parce qu'on est juste ça s'est passé
pendant des vacances scolaires donc on a
parlé uniquement de ça alors que tout
simplement il s'était en plus c'était un
mineur un mineur qui a effectivement
tiré un coup de pied dans une bombe
lacrymogène et qui a explosé à ce
moment-là mais la policière et je sais
j'avais pris des tout de suite des
nouvelles de sa santé rapidement elle
n'est pas n'a pas été hospitalisée
pendant plusieurs jours elle est
ressortie dès le lendemain matin et elle
est rentrée chez elle donc c'est vrai
qu'on a fait beaucoup de choses le
ministre est venu mais je pense que
aussi la sécurité ne dépend pas que tu
mets de Montigny c'est un pouvoir
régalien de l'État donc j'attends aussi
que le ministre de l'Intérieur renforce
aussi les dispositifs sur le centre de
Montigny qui est un centre un peu
particulier avec une gare un centre
commercial un théâtre
un campus universitaire donc vous voyez
bien que il y a énormément de passages
d'ailleurs la de Montigny avec 70000
passages jours et la deuxième gare en
terme de fréquentation sur le territoire
du département du centre commercial on
va y rester on va juste traverser la rue
l'espace Skywest qui doit être renouvelé
ça fait plus d'un an les travaux ont dû
retard ce centre avait été lancé pour
encore dynamiser l'offre commerciale sur
Montigny-le-Bretonneux force et de
constater que c'est un échec le centre
doit se renouveler la là aussi du mal à
se renouveler ça en est où actuellement
est-ce que la municipalité s'est occupée
de ce dossier est-ce que vous vous
penchez dessus qu'elle répond vous allez
apporter attendez la municipalité n'est
pas propriétaire du centre le centre
aujourd'hui et avoir un centre
commercial et qui se déserte sur sa vie
commerciale qui se déserte pour mieux
rebondir c'est ça surtout donc
honnêtement de retard dans les travaux
on est bien obligé mais oui un an de
retard sur les travaux parce que
justement pour ça donc il y a des
recours qui sont déposés et ensuite il y
a des problèmes de non-concurrence aussi
qui est existent entre l'est de Paris et
le projet que nous avons sur sur
Montigny tout ça je veux dire ça fait
partie de
le travail que doivent faire les
propriétaires la ville n'est pas
propriétaire nous on est là pour essayer
d'encourager les choses de faire en
sorte que ça se passe dans des dans le
respect des textes que nous avons
surmontine Bretonneux mais
malheureusement je peux pas faire plus
si ce n'est d'être vigilant sur ce qui
va se passer un dernier mot votre
candidat aux candidat socialiste votre
opposant aux prochaines élections ce
sera Vivien gaz qu'il remplace Sandrine
Gangan qui elle était candidate en 2008
qui depuis a quitté à la municipalité
elle est partie sur la ville de Trappes
c'est la responsable fédérale du PS
d'ailleurs responsable dans le
département Vivien gaz un mot sur lui
sur cette opposant vous l'avez déjà
rencontré vous avez échangé avec lui
déjà je l'ai croisé mais c'est quelqu'un
que je ne connais pas qui arrive sur
Montigny depuis quelques mois donc c'est
un candidat de passage merci Michel
legier d'être venu sur ce plateau
candidat pour un nouveau mandat en mars
prochain avec le soutien en tout cas de
l'UMP local peut-être au niveau national
ce sera décidé dans les prochaines
semaines merci à vous merci à vous
bonsoir on part comme souvent si vous
nous suivez régulièrement à Maurepas pas
moins d'une demi douzaine de candidats
sont déjà plus ou moins déclarés la
situation s'éclaircit un peu avec l'UMP
qui a finalement tranché l'instance
départementale réuni en comité à
désigner Grégory garestiaire responsable
UMP local pour porter ses couleurs il
s'était déclaré depuis le mois de mars
il siège au conseil municipal de
Maurepas depuis la fin du mois de
septembre je vous propose d'écouter sa
réaction
c'est à dire je suis très heureux que ma
famille politique à laquelle
j'appartiens depuis sa création
mais fait confiance pour cette élection
municipale et pour la représenter en
tant que tête de liste
c'est le choix de la cohérence c'est le
choix du Mérite de la confiance et puis
c'est le choix du renouvellement voilà
je pense que ma famille politique a
aussi misé sur le renouvellement
vraiment des générations à Maurepas dont
on avait tant besoin pour préparer
l'alternance ma légitimité voilà est
reconnue off
icielle les pairs et j'en suis très
heureux et je remercie également tous
mes soutiens je remercie surtout mon
député Jean-Frédéric Poisson
préféré Grégory garesti à Pierre Le
Guérinel l'ancien premier adjoint au
maire l'ancien Premier Adjoint udi au
maire Georges Mougeot le maire sortant à
Pierre Le Guérinel qui avait pourtant le
soutien dans le département de Valérie
Pécresse la patronne de l'UMP et
départementale il se dit forcément déçu
contrairement à ce qu'on pourrait
imaginer c'est pas de la déception ni de
l'amertume mais c'est de la surprise
parce que je suis toujours surpris que
on peut dire qu'on fasse pas les bons
calculs
je suis surpris parce que jouer la carte
du chacun il va seul au premier tour bon
après tout c'est légitime mais c'est un
test de créer une dynamique forte et ça
c'est un peu gênant d'autant que ce que
j'imagine pas mais en mettant les choses
au pire si c'est de la conduire par
exemple à perdre la ville elles sont
très mauvais calculs pour l'UMP parce
que ça fait perdre dans le même temps
les voies des grands électeurs dans
certains auront besoin pour les
sénatoriales
la reconquête et la Transformer donc je
suis un peu surpris qu'il n'est pas
réalisé à quel point il serait un risque
et puis à noter que d'autres
investitures viennent d'être donné par
l'UMP des Yvelines on peut citer
Jean-Michel fourgouse
à Saint-Cyr-l'École de mer sortant les
noms étant connu à l'UMP les premiers
meeting vont donc débuter à Bois-d'Arcy
Philippe Benassaya annonce son lancement
de campagne jeudi 17 octobre à 20h à la
salle Maurice Chevalier conseiller
municipal d'opposition il tentera de
dépasser les 21 %, 5 de son prédécesseur
François Rivière au premier tour des
municipales de 2008 dans cette ville il
devrait être posé au socialiste Claude
Vihiers 80 ans qui souhaite obtenir un
nouveau mandat à moins que son parti le
Parti socialiste ne fasse un autre choix
dans les prochaines semaines on en
revient à Maurepas lui aussi à commencer
sa campagne Michel Eve vous ne le verrez
pas pour autant distribuer des tracts
sur le marché il ne veut pas faire de
propagande électoralistes dit-il son
programme sera distribué directement
dans les boîtes aux lettres il promet
des idées novatrices inattendues et pas
question de s'allier derrière le PS ou
encore les Verts
non puisqu'on refuse toute étiquette
c'est à dire que l'étiquette politique
est-ce sclérosante dans notre réflexion
j'ai accompagné Georges Mougeot durant
quatre mandats dont trois en tant que
mère adjoint chargé des sports et
j'estime que les contrats ont été
remplis on a baptisé notre liste avec
trois épithètes qui sont signifiants
c'est une liste citoyenne solidaire et
associative solidaire parce qu'on ne
tient pas à laisser enfin on fera on
prendra à gare à ne pas laisser des gens
sur le côté donc financièrement c'est à
dire que on décrétera qu'il y aura pas
d'augmentation de la taxe locale la taxe
d'habitation
associatif parce qu'effectivement on en
est une émanation associative enfin bon
nombre de polystères et de colistiers
sont issus de d'associations et pas
seulement sportive et puis citoyenne
parce que citoyenne on envisage tout un
programme autour de l'éducation civique
en direction des jeunes et puis on est
un carrefour intergénérationnel on
réserve aux morts-patial dans notre
programme des orientations
atypiques mais mais riche de créativité
simplement parce que cette liste va
conjuguer l'expérience pour une toute
petite part puisqu'il y a deux ou trois
anciens élus du conseil municipal et
tout le reste ce sont des personnes qui
sont nouvelles et qui donc arrivent avec
des idées une créativité une originalité
qui fait du bien
dans un instant je recevrai Alexandra
rozetti ancienne première adjointe au
maire de voisin le Bretonneux à la
quitté la majorité UMP pour annoncer sa
candidature en mars elle attend le
soutien notamment de l'UDI je vous
propose d'écouter pour l'instant
Jean-Loup Carriat candidat moddem à
Guyancourt trois noms sont connus à ce
jour sur cette ville la dyslas courtra
pour l'UMP et François de Ligny merci
sortant pour le Parti socialiste cela
fait plus d'une mandature que nous
sommes à plantés sur Guyancourt nous
avons déjà présenté une liste aux
précédents élections municipales et nous
renouvelerons cet essai pour mars 2014
nos ambitions c'est d'essayer de faire
un très bon score a Guyancourt parce
qu'il nous semble que le contexte a
beaucoup changé par rapport aux
élections précédentes et que nous avons
nos chances de gagner il y a de plus en
plus de gens qui s'aperçoivent que
Guyancourt est une ville très séparée
sur lequel il faut mettre du liant de la
démocratie locale des commerces de
proximité et tout ça ça n'existe pas
aiguillancour T et ça nous voulons
travailler là-dessus cette candidature
de Jean-Loup carriac qui intervient
après le départ de Julien hochly
ancienne tête de liste du Modem sur
Guyancourt il a décidé maintenant de se
rapprocher du mers sortant c'est un
choix personnel qu'il a fait que nous
regrettons mais il a fait ce choix de
quitter le modem et de quitter donc
notre travail c'est un choix personnel
je reçois donc Alexandra Rosetti bonsoir
ancienne premier adjointe au maire de
Voisins-le-Bretonneux Alexis billet tu
MP ancienne première adjointe car
aujourd'hui vous siégé dans l'opposition
vous avez annoncé votre et démission le
premier octobre lors du conseil
municipal vous avez annoncé aussi votre
propre candidature en mars prochain
contre le maire sortant Alexis Viet
pourquoi ce choix mais parce que je
n'étais plus d'accord avec les choix qui
étaient faits par l'équipe majoritaire
alors j'ai pendant 10 ans pendant ces
dernières années en particulier
m'a dit ce que j'avais à dire je dirais
de façon en interne et puis après bien
tout le monde se plie on voit tous
ensemble de façon solidaire et comme là
je ne suis vraiment plus d'accord je me
suis dit qu'il était peut-être temps de
ne plus être solidaire justement vous
n'êtes pas d'accord sur quoi quels sont
les mauvais choix vous l'avez dit lors
de votre intervention au Conseil dernier
conseil municipal je ne veux plus être
solidaire des choix humains politiques
financiers de l'équipe majoritaire
quelles sont ses choix que vous dénoncez
alors je trouve pas particulièrement
déstabilisant le discours par exemple du
de l'adjoint au finances qui nous qui
nous dit depuis
maintenant quelques temps que la
situation financière s'aggrave ce qui
est tout à fait vrai puisque comme dans
toutes les communes il y a une baisse
des dotations de l'État ou en plus nous
avons une baisse des habitants donc nos
recettes baissent nous sommes de plus en
plus en plus fonctionné pour dans un but
de solidarité je dirais avec les autres
communes nous avons aussi des
contraintes de l'État qui nous pèsent de
plus en plus comme ce qui va arriver
avec les rives scolaires avec les 25% de
logements sociaux qui sont attendus et
qui si nous n'arrivons pas à remplir nos
obligations et bien nous avons des
pénalités donc ça fait que effectivement
il y a tout un ensemble de mesures qui
qui arrivent et qui font qui mettent la
commune dans une vraie situation
financière difficile et nous continuons
malgré tout à faire des choix qui à mon
sens ne sont plus utiles ils sont les
priorités aujourd'hui puisque vous allez
présenter votre liste quelles sont vos
priorités dans le programme alors ma
priorité déjà c'est de mener une
politique de bon sens vraiment je crois
que c'est le mot le plus important pour
moi c'est à dire il faut absolument
qu'on se recentre sur les besoins réels
des vicinois je peux prendre par exemple
une démarche qualité ISO 9001 qui a été
lancé depuis l'année dernière en mairie
cette démarche qualité a pour but de
certifier les services à la population
très bien sauf que nos services à
population à mon sens sont déjà très
bons et donc cette certification ne nous
coûte pas moins que 50 000 euros c'est à
dire un poste entier dédié à ça
c'est-à-dire minimum 25000 euros plus un
cabinet d'outils 25000 euros qui va et
bien non parce que on est en situation
difficile donc je pense que les vicinois
n'ont pas besoin je dirais que leur
service soit certifié pour se rendre
compte qu'il fonctionne bien et que ce
sont de bons services donc ça c'est un
exemple parmi d'autres il y a également
une multiplication depuis quelques temps
et même depuis quelques années des coups
d'études c'est à dire qu'on ne peut plus
rien faire dans cette ville sans passer
par des études alors les cabinets
d'études
non là je parle par exemple on veut
refaire les huisseries sur la commune
c'est à dire les volets les fenêtres bon
très bien sur la commune sur les écoles
de la commune et bien on prend un
cabinet d'études ça nous coûte 30 000
euros je veux dire on peut peut-être
faire des devis vous voyez ce que je
veux dire je pense qu'il y a des il y a
des études nécessaires je parle pas de
d'appel d'offres je parle bien de frais
d'études donc si on doit refaire un
bâtiment tel que de Coville par exemple
évidemment qu'il nous faut des études il
nous faut un architecte mais je pense
qu'il y a des des moyens de faire des
économies aussi sur ces postes-là donc
en fait c'est une série si vous voulez
de mesures je ne suis pas la seule à
dénoncer ça dans l'équipe du conseil
municipal est-ce que d'autres vont vous
suivre est-ce que vous êtes en contact
avec d'autres membres de la majorité
pour monter la future liste de mars non
pas spécialement parce que je pense que
les autres membres de l'équipe ont fait
le choix malgré tout de continuer à
suivre cette politique c'est à dire que
je ne suis pas la seule à dire je ne
suis pas d'accord les autres l'ont dit
et d'ailleurs sur cette démarche qualité
je peux dire que la majorité des membres
de l'équipe était contre la décision a
été prise puisque le maire bien sûr
apprend la décision c'est souverains et
c'est normal si les autres élus
continuent préfèrent continuer à suivre
ce genre de mouvement je veux dire libre
à eux je ne vais pas essayer d'aller
débaucher de la majorité actuelle sur
votre liste en mars pour l'instant non
mais vous savez je suis je démarre je
suis en démarrage de construction mais
en tout cas je n'irai pas chercher à
détruire la liste que le maire est en
train de monter c'est pas du tout mon
but au contraire je pense qu'il faut de
nouveaux regards parce que c'est très
difficile pour un système de se
renouveler de l'intérieur je pense aussi
c'est humain le maire est là depuis 18
ans trois mandats il y a un bon bilan
enfin je veux dire je peux pas renier le
bilan en plus j'ai participé pendant 12
ans mais je crois que c'est peut-être un
peu compliqué de se remettre en question
au bout de temps et je pense qu'on a
besoin justement de nouveau regard donc
de nouvelles personnes aussi on va
parler de nouvelles personnes avec qui
vous allez mener cette cette liste on
parle d'une personne que sur la ville de
voisins qui sur la ville de voisins est
plutôt connu c'est Joël le nom c'est
l'actuel vice-président de l'UDI dans le
département lui aussi avait d'ailleurs
quitté la majorité le conseil municipal
pour aller siéger ensuite dans
l'opposition face à lexibiat au
précédentes élections 2008 ce qui avait
entraîné d'ailleurs une triangulaire
mais on aura le temps de repriser tout
ça dans les dans les prochaines semaines
en tout cas vous aujourd'hui vous allez
vous rapprocher de Joël le nom oui alors
je précisais que avant je le nom déjà je
veux dire ça fait trois fois que le
premier adjoint quand même je dirais
démissionne et monte monte sa propre
liste donc voilà c'est quand même pas
anodin aussi ça veut bien dire que aussi
la démocratie s'exerce évidemment je
vais maintenant j'ai rencontré les
membres de son association et après leur
avoir exposé ma vision des choses et ce
qui m'inquiétait je pense que j'ai
vraiment rapporté remporté l'adhésion
donc vous aurez le soutien de l'UDI pour
les prochaines élections alors ça c'est
en cours de discussion j'ai vu que les
sujets précédents montraient à quel
point c'était compliqué alors je suis à
l'UDI j'étais avant à l'UDF j'étais
avant modem donc moi ce qui m'importe
c'est que les gens me voient bien comme
quelqu'un de centriste ça ça a toujours
été je n'ai jamais varié là dessus et ce
qui m'intéresse c'est les valeurs du
centre c'est le travail le mérite la
reconnaissance la justice voilà c'est ça
qui m'intéresse après bon bah les
accords je dirais les les arrangements
entre appareils de partie bon bah voilà
on a vu dans les sujets d'avant à quel
point c'est compliqué forcément Alexis
Viet lui demande aussi avoir
l'investiture de l'UDI dans le cadre
d'accord avec l'UMP ça s'est plutôt au
niveau national mais en tout cas lui dit
sur le secteur de 50 ans en Yvelines
l'UDI 50 ans en Yvelines a publié un
billet sur son blog et dit ne pas avoir
été consulté par cette initiative par
votre démission et dans l'attente des
investitures nationales elle renouvelle
s'inscrire complètement dans la majorité
actuelle porté par le maire de
Voisins-le-Bretonneux c'est à dire que
l'UDI 50 ans soutient le maire de
Voisins-le-Bretonneux j'aurais peut-être
pas voilà en fait il y a un petit peu
compliqué voilà moi je suis Monsieur le
nom d'ailleurs et secrétaire général de
partie radicale je suis entourée de
plusieurs personnes
votre situation
d'arrangement voilà sur la liste du
maire il y a des udies qui sont plutôt
ici du Nouveau Centre moi je suis plutôt
entourée de gens qui sont issus du Parti
radical j'ai envie de dire moi toutes
ces querelles de parties ne m'intéresse
pas beaucoup je viens de le dire moi ce
qui m'intéresse c'est les valeurs qui
sont portées par le Centre
candidature bien sûr
c'est pas ça qui guide mon choix voilà
je suis constante dans mes choix parce
que j'ai toujours été au centre et voilà
c'est tout ce qui m'intéresse mon parti
ses voisins voilà merci Alexandra
Rosetti conseiller en municipal
maintenant d'opposition un voisin le
Bretonneux c'est la fin de cette édition
de municipale 2014 prochain rendez-vous
politique sur TVfil donc un jour le 29
octobre les programmes qui se
poursuivent sur TV fils